why do you think why do you think
coordinated dance cuz it's so beautiful
right now now people just grind on each
other and they don't know how to [ __ ]
dance yeah but like Latin cultures they
all know how to dance
yeah there's my daughter at three I
swear to God at three years old she can
already dance yeah maybe she was
watching her mom and her grandma or
maybe it's just in her cultural I don't
know but use it they got it man yeah
everything they all know how to dance
with each other they know the moves they
learn how to do it so what has happened
in America that nobody knows how to
[ __ ] race rich people don't have
dance there's no reason interesting when
you're poor that's the reason why like
poor people are cool they have swag they
have to you don't have the opportunity
to just go you're my life now when
you're poor you got a kick game when
you're poor you gotta have flashy ways
to speak to somebody because you don't
have money to be flashy you have to
maximize every other part of your
ability to get [ __ ] right that's you
don't have experience you don't have cut
you're not good in conversations you got
to stick out some help that's why the
hood dudes found a way to make cheap
[ __ ] cool converse became cool it's a
twenty dollar sneaker wear like this
baggy ass Dickies pants became cool wear
like this right burritos do burritos
were poor food all of it pizza yeah yeah
so it's like that's why it's dope so
dance is just one of those things you're
some Dominican dude who just came here
you just got a job driving some Liberty
cab uptown and the height you got to
find a way to get [ __ ] you know you
can't get it from money but you could
take your girl and that's that floor
start the bachata my shrew absolutely so
we just all be poor do we do cool people
stop being do rich people stop being
cool it's cool jay-z looks like Janelle
Monae now we'd [ __ ] dork trying to
grow facial hair like me yeah yeah yeah
it's awful it's stupid yeah so look at
any the only persons maintain as cool
even though he's rich is did he probably
yeah it's just the only one and he's
just really killed Tupac
but maybe he killed Tupac but he also
just become Italian so what is he doing
he's just copying some other poor people
right
yeah that's well that's well that's you
know it's funny you say that my father
who's you know up self-proclaim Inouye
did the answer she um I found them I'm
almost 80% German hide it
wait Suncheon come on [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did it Nazis to lose a [ __ ] joke
but he said you know things well you're
smart though yeah but he said you know
he told me you know I remember watching
the Bronx Tale in the 90s he's from the
Bronx and all that you know in the
Italian culture and the black culture he
was you know each other well but but the
reason why he said is because they both
the thing that he thought they had in
common was they're poor that's what he
thought he was like you know we're both
poor like the Mafia guys a lot of unless
you're at the top a lot of these guys
don't have money they're flashy and they
have cash and stuff but it's not real
he's like saying with the blacks we
don't really have that much money so our
cultures came together and that's a guy
who's got an eighth grade education and
even he saw that very easily it's like
we're all poor here so we copied chunks
like in Brooklyn we've had conversations
like when we were doing benders and and
your character was like this typical
kind of like I guess it was Queens but
yeah like it was a outer borough Italian
dude
yeah and they had him wearing like
construction boots and [ __ ] and he goes
now you'd understand like our generation
wears Jordans right yeah we grew up
really influenced by black culture
absolutely that was the predominant
culture it's the only the only culture
in the world
rich would like an old-school blue
collar white pretty much predominantly
white work working-class neighborhood
the only reason I was able to ever even
to get respect for my friends or get all
the friends that I have is through
basketball because I could play basket
which was a black sport meritocracy man
I could just play that thing well yeah
and now I could speak to everybody cuz I
was just a standout player right and my
friends who are and we're left behind it
didn't relate to you I'm getting skull
[ __ ] fine oh no Jamal didn't know what
that meant but I could hit
three-pointers from anywhere so he's
like you cool what is wild it's like
it's wild when something gets so extreme
how it becomes its opposite right I was
just thinking about that like in jail
when someone has that happen to them
which is basically what you had happen
yeah obviously it's more extreme in jail
it's the most masculine
thing but what they're doing is a gay
act but it's when you get that's why
it's like liberals have gotten so far
right that I'm so far left that they're
now right yeah now right yeah now the
right ones are going like free speech
free speech they're becoming left yeah
though the the left used to be the ones
be like hey man hey whatever Lincoln oh
[ __ ] Abraham Lincoln was a Republican
yeah it's it's like nature has a limit
and you can't the farther you go you
just come just like the universe you
come back to where you started
absolutely Wow oh yes Bob yes go to this
side of the screen you come out the
other yeah because what those kids did
to you is like that's how dudes
that's how dudes like and do the most
masculine horror that that's toxic
masculinity bullying is toxic masculine
and the worst thing you can do is we got
guys who just witness a Yanis Papa's
brain moment like that's how your brain
works yeah yeah we just figured out how
okay no no like yes well you see on is's
tweets they're really well worked out we
just witnessed before it gets tight it's
true it's yeah yeah yeah I do umami I do
a hundred drafts and then I just [ __ ]
yeah yeah but it's a cool moment for you
because you're leaving in ten minutes if
that was your everyday life like it is -
it's just a whole string a long [ __ ]
day Johnny long day